Hey youtubers, it's Charlie! Happy Black Friday,
hopefully you haven't spent all your money.
But there's a Batman v Superman Teaser Trailer
that's coming on Monday during Gotham, so
I'm going to play the promo clip that they
aired for the talk about a couple other big
rumors inside the DC TV universe is the hardest
class planet that manifests Superman one time
Batman versus you know as soon as I mean this
is such a ferocious character I like I don't
think Batman you versus I go Batman Superman
is Superman menthols you know do through the
Batman Batman is the way is obviously superpowers
this revision will you referred to an exclusive
sneak of Batman versus Superman in the this
Monday on Fox I like the fact that Butch is
one of the only people who is like yeah I
think Superman Superman would totally when
I'm not getting it fired in my I think it's
a real shame they didn't put the actor the
place Bruce Wayne and that they think it just
had a look at the camera and stare like just
clear to the lands of his best Batman gays
when I'm expecting from this Batman view Superman
teaser trailer is just a smaller version of
what we got with Captain America Civil War
that was actually a pretty big Charles was
surprised when Jimmy Kimmel posted that it
sounds like there's going to be quite a bit
of new footage at some icy pretty pumped but
for those you that are asking me about the
Supergirl flash crossover rumors and Constantine
legends of tomorrow stuff is I feel like a
whole bunch of stuff going on of the DC universe
right now most of the TV universe I was we
have Batman view Superman stuff coming up
to Padilla Supergirl first and if you like
that the bigger deal because they said before
Supergirl season one of the CBS executives
were like we kinda want to keep her to ourselves
but the rumor is is because Supergirl is only
currently picked up for the 13 episode run
is like an option for the back nine episodes
of this is the way most television shows work
the pick it up for like a certain block episodes
and if it's really successful forgiven a budget
extra episodes so the rumor goes because they
want to try and choose Supergirl ratings is
much as possible they want to do like a big
crazy event and that would be crossover with
the flash so that that's why they're open
to it you want to do something really big
in the spring Warner Bros. is also can have
Batman versus Superman dropping so it just
makes sense they would try to do some big
DC crossover event the funny thing about that
of course is that the order have legends of
tomorrow coming which is kinda like their
big 13 episode crossover event so I think
because that existed because being hype so
much everyone to just getting more on board
with big TV crossovers so until they explain
how this crossover will work ominous stick
to what I said earlier and say Supergirl is
just on a different earth from where the flash
and arrow are right now we will call her earth
three although technically in the DC universe
earth three is the crime syndicate earth in
their count of doing that with earth two on
the flash season two right now all things
are possible in the multi-verse you can actually
think of the movies is happening on a different
earth inside the multi-verse but I am pretty
excited I know a lot of you guys asked me
about Supergirl like I just I don't do a lot
of Supergirl videos because it overlaps with
a lot of other videos during a very busy part
of the week but it is a fun show in the tone
is very similar to the flash so course it
makes sense that she would crossover the flash
but if it does happen I totally think that
they will have her do a foot race with the
flash I mean how could you not to that within
the big news is Constantine is rumored to
be going on legends of tomorrow season two
this is kind of premature to just because
they haven't even finished shooting legends
of tomorrow season one the reason why he wouldn't
go on legends of tomorrow season one is because
they the pretty much finished writing all
the episodes so to try and work committed
this point would be almost impossible from
a scheduling perspective they haven't picked
up legends of tomorrow for season two yet
so there's a lot of things that have to happen
before they can get Constantine on the series
but it's totally doable in Matt Ryan is totally
down to come back for anything they want to
use them for really is just a matter scheduling
and finding the right story for him to come
back for like they brought him back he would
have to be for some big mystical storyline
Vandal Savage kinda does get into that but
I will I would totally like to see them get
into some of the demonology of the DC universe
if you going to do that you might as well
do it on your big crazy action series but
just to be clear all these rumors about Supergirl
and Constantine are all very plausible like
there'd they're totally doable is just a matter
of the network say okay yeah let's do this
the thing that does give me a lot of hope
for all this is the fact that Warner Bros.
is choosing to promote their biggest film
is coming up on another network if it wasn't
clear though Bruno Heller that the show runner
for Gotham has a deal at Warner Bros. he developed
Gotham for Warner Bros. television they produce
the show is just that they sold it to Fox
Bruno Heller has a similar deal at Warner
Bros. television as Greg Bramante does like
they both develop a budget TV shows for Warner
Bros. which is not all the shows year on networks
that Warner Bros. owns so they can do that
than they can totally make a deal with CBS
work and then they can actually go to Gotham
and say hey look we were able to do this big
Supergirl CBS crossover with the flash why
don't we try this with Gotham now so that
proves anything to guys it just shows that
networks will try anything if they think that
it will make their shows more successful so
what can happen on Monday because that Batman
v Superman video I'll do that first on Monday
night then I'll do my Gotham midseason finale
video so be sure to subscribe to get that
I shall have to do some sort of Batman seemed
giveaway I was doing the reverse flash ring
giveaway string like flash arrow Supergirl
video so that NAFTA like tie something up
with got them in Batman so while you guys
wait for my next video to post and I'm still
finishing Jessica Jones you guys can click
here for the Star Wars trailer that I posted
yesterday and you can click here for the Captain
America Civil War trailer from earlier this
week thank you so much for watching, everybody
let's high five and I'll see you guys tonight!